herzlich zur heutigen video ich bin
jetzt zu sagen mit herrn jedoch
interessieren wo und wie heute mal
wieder einen starter pack video wir
haben niemand anderen als den menschen
hinter der kamera
die höhe werden so herzlich beschwören
hauptstadt bei der kamera
ihr kennt die regeln
das starterfeld an und dann hatte sie
abwechselnd mit der dreimal ein katana
die leute verstehen müssen einmal ein
billiger als erster youtuber ist dann
vermutlich ansage von anfang an dicke
nein überhaupt nicht
aber dort ansage gesagt ich lasse mein
geld wandert das ist so eine
umschreibung vielleicht dafür arbeitet
also das hat damit was tun
das beendet vielleicht gibt es ja nicht
the world mitarbeiter ganz vom bbi
starter pack wie man zu den wird nichts
passiert eine classic trichter regionale
geschichte gut für mich voll gemein wird
auch für dich du kannst einfach keine
ahnung die katze ja mit mir drauf ohne
marco wirklicher gewonnen erklärte
beraten oder im büro also die man nur
schwer und young 35
aber dass du da warst du den berg aber
versucht kennen wir nicht
30.10 nie gesehen hatte eine studie eine
keiner macht man aber an weg wurde wird
brandet sich ja nicht auf die satten
braucht eine papierfabrik tiefer winter
zu verschlucken
eine sage er nicht doch er kann ja immer
stark vergrössern und wir uns gleich
damit wieder aufgemacht haben um dein
bekommen der begriff glück
[Musik]
sein bruder schornberg dabei wie
zusammen völlig basic bedingt eine
anspielung bürgerbüro ihr herz zu legen
wenn europas warst du auch noch
erschwinglich
zudem denkt denkt man an die hohe
qualität einer cd verdeutlicht meine 100
prozent qualität qualität logo ein
verbrauch von 2 1 ab jetzt muss ich ja
gleich sieben mal nehmen indem einfach
ein bild von der kamerad macher keiner
wer ein quintett dürfte auch der grund
für den markt dürften wir mit dem
überrascht wendel und gucken wir auf
plötzlich also ich kann auch nicht sagen
wir kriegen weil niemand liebt
gegenwärtige musste der fall wird das
ist ein drittel seien dort im winter
herrscht
wenn wir doch im moment höre ich einfach
ganz studiere kamera macht machst du
erstmal noch nicht zu 100 prozent sicher
respekt ich danke specht warum deswegen
hätten die goldene statue mich dass der
schuldige meint im letzten monat gemacht
meinte rettig am ende wurde mit mehrheit
und wird widmet eine komplette küche
erträge gleich mit nicht glücklicher
sagt dann hast du konnten aber ein
hier ist auf qualitäts logo race day
long turbo start perfekt unterhalten
doch das formale der regel aber wer
rückt mit feindbildern sind von einer
kamera bewegen europa zu retten er war
der start wegen punkte machen wir ja
jetzt kein name bei ich glaube dass man
ja ja ja also ist auch als koch brüder
aber die manager also ja die övp in
sachen macht man wenig betrieb statt
euch beide vielleicht auch den mini
trachten
beim nächsten alles oder nichts okay das
ist auf die nachrichten da hat einfach
in sich
ich muss sagen dass die stadt irgendwie
ja keine ahnung aber noch einmal ich
habe mitbekommen dass die groß genug war
ort kommt
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ganz nach 105 zentimeter tief in meinen
büchern entweder objekten freuen erklärt
um einen ton von nachricht überhaupt